[Music]
this is what the Internet's gonna do
it's gonna turn a ton of normal people
into different versions of celebrity not
everyone most people will never get to
charli's level most people not amassed
10 million followers on a platform let
alone a single platform overall but
everybody is in a place of fifteen
hundred three thousand and guess what
and you probably remember this three
thousand feels like 10 million you got
your prospective YouTube what's up so so
grateful that you clicked and you're
about to watch a new youtube video but
before you do 2 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 that
is my texting community platform doing a
lot of one-on-one engagement in there
and also access opportunity first looks
in that environment 2 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1
join it now and now to the video you've
been wanting to watch everybody it's
gary vaynerchuk really excited about
this conversation in today's podcast
when it crossed my mind you know
basically how i live my life as random
thoughts come in and occasionally i
execute on them so had a random thought
a couple weeks ago maybe a month ago
inviting this family to the show to kind
of talk about the phenomenon that has
happened with their daughters tick tock
obviously anybody who's listening right
now is super aware of what i believe in
the platform and what's been going on on
it and how it maps historically to
social networks and more importantly why
i believe in a far majority of people
it's a very important opportunity to
jump into because the amount of
attention the platform has versus how
much content is being produced is an
arbitrage that can lead to a lot of
opportunities one of the real fun in my
opinion phenomenons on tick-tock is has
been the explosion of
both of these young ladies starting with
one of these young ladies and I'm gonna
let everybody introduce themselves here
but I also have their parents here I had
the luxury of meeting the entire family
maybe three weeks ago and may for my
team always paying attention to the
cultures like you should meet these guys
I'm like of course we had a really nice
Chad they were just really lovely people
and I really want them to win and more
importantly selfishly I think that in
our culture today there's an enormous
amount of confusion and misunderstanding
of social networks and and to be very
very very frank I think most parents
struggle with the behaviors that I think
are both most beneficial to their
children and and by no means do I even
have any real clue what's going on in
this household but but I'm intuitive
enough and I've been watching enough
that I feel very confident there'll be
some stories and conversations here that
will help an enormous amount of people
listening both for inspiring creators
but for also parents and executives that
are trying to understand the dynamics
and and we have some very different
voices in this room all of which come
from a different angle of the story so
we're gonna go around right now I'm
gonna introduce ourselves and and then
I've got some questions and we'll Jam
and we'll take it from there so mom as
the queen bee of the family we'll start
with you and go around the circle who
are you and my name is Heidi Charlie in
Dixie's mom understood Charlie I'm
Charlie D'Amelio and I danced on
ticked-off
fair enough I'm Dixie Julia that mark
D'Amelio
I'm father to these two wonderful young
ladies and husband to Heidi and glad to
be here thanks for having us so let's so
for a lot of people who may not know
right now they're still probably curious
based on those intros let's really go
into the origin to paint the picture
what happened how did your tik-tok life
start like and I'm talking about when
did you first find out about it were you
on musically how did it hit your radar
what happened with your first video
and then and then we'll take it from
there so I was actually just Charlie for
everybody was just thing good yeah I was
actually never on musically I got an
account for maybe about three days
posted five or six videos then deleted
it never looked on it again and that was
like four or five years ago yeah okay
about and you're how old right now I'm
15 okay go ahead so my friends at the
end of last school year we would all go
into the bathroom and they'd be like
look at this cool little dance I found
and he'd be like charlie learn it
because I'm a dancer and they would post
me on their accounts this is before I
even had a Tech Talk account so late
last so we're talking now April May of
2019 you know you like every normal
teenager go to the bathroom with your
friends and they're there looking at
these videos and they're trying to get
you to replicate that dance because they
knew that you probably could and some of
them couldn't so I could teach them
understood and they were posting me on
their accounts I hadn't even downloaded
the app yet but it was so cool because
there was all these fun little dances to
do and everyone was just posting them so
eventually end of May I would say I
think was when my first video came out I
decided to make a Tech Talk account and
I was just dancing doing what I do
everyday what I've been doing since I
was three I've been a dancer my entire
life and threw out real glamour yeah
prior to your account in late May had
any of the videos on your friends
accounts of you dancing go viral or hit
a lot of views great keep going
so throughout the summer I was just
posting videos dancing if you like an
investigative Barbara Walters here on
the scene keep it up guys and then it
was before I was going to a dance class
with that was about an hour and a half
away from my house I just made a dance
video very very quickly it was a duet
with someone named moved with joy and it
was a very simple dance she makes these
adorable simple dances for that anyone
can do so I did it I do added her video
and then I got
car on my way to a dance class that I've
I've been going to dance class my whole
life but I kept checking and I was like
why is this getting so many views why is
this getting so many likes I'm not doing
anything I'm just dancing like this is
it was insane to me what what number
post was it for you
on your account it was probably around
like 15 got it so the first 14 just are
super normal nothing crazy you know you
literally have very few if any followers
besides your friends yeah and now this
duet goes and it goes viral it goes
viral uh it got up to around two hundred
thousand likes which was and how many
views I think it got up to like 1.4
million and so by the time you got to
your class an hour and a half later
you're like oh [ __ ] I have a viral
tik-tok video yes and you're pumped and
texting your friends I didn't say
anything to anyone interesting I was
just talking to my mom the whole time
okay I even like what do I do
cuz I was like oh my god did this 50
likes what yeah like I happily seemed
crazy that was insane to me and then it
just kept growing yeah this is good [ __ ]
she's like oh my god what do we do what
do I do
alright people liking it why this one I
would I give us this the others were
more intricate sure they were so much
harder yeah yeah and she was like so she
goes in and she comes out she was like
my god she goes into class yeah an hour
for three and a half hours okay sorry
kids are dancing for hours all right
long ride home she's saying what am I
gonna do what am I gonna do I'm like
charlie are you gonna do me another one
I don't know that's a really good point
Heidi and I think like I think this is
actually the first thing I want to spend
time on I am fascinated by people being
very comfortable to create when they
feel like a very small group of people
are watching and then what it does to
their psyche the moment they realize way
more are the fact that you really spent
a lot of time saying what will I do
which probably seemed funny to your mom
she's like what is she talking about
makes a lot of sense to me because I
believe
most people massively overthink their
content because they're worried about
judgment and thus it changes their
behavior
so that's really what did happen that
makes sense you were like did you feel
this is a great I really want your
answer did you feel a heightened may be
extreme pressure for your next post
because you wanted it to be good yes I
actually didn't post for about two days
after that it's interesting stuff yes
it's really interesting stuff because I
was nervous I was like now I have no
I've done the liver yeah no it has to be
good and my next post is just another
video of me dancing in my bedroom so and
how did that do it went viral
yeah so really it went back-to-back cuz
a lot of people have something go viral
and then it goes right back to normal
but literally your next video also
wimpin it's in ever since that video
I've had every video go viral right say
okay a lot of views yeah which is after
the first one you didn't post for two
days what's the conversation with you
and your inner circle you and your
sister you and your friends was it a
holy [ __ ] this happened what are we
talking maybe black so at that point
took touch this usually july-august that
right sorry right yeah the first one was
in late May the 15th or so wasn't so you
guys are in summer yeah so what's the
scene like what happens in those 48
hours are you like strategizing with
your homies no I was going to the pool
with my friends
I know did anyone know um somebody
people that followed yeah but I wasn't
talking about it a lot because I was
like it's Tech Talk it's like not cool
yeah it wasn't like to wear this yeah
that's right let's talk about that
because that's why I want you guys on
because I want people to learn to your
point and this is what this is how so
much can happen just to paint the
picture and confirm this for me Charlie
if we're talking this summer not it was
you're you're 14 at the time or 15 15 to
your point this is where I don't think
people understand literally six months
ago to a 15 year old girl
tik-tok is not cool it was skewing a
little younger right like 8 9 10 11 12
for sure it like guys were not on it at
all ish or just kind of tiny bit so just
an
we're here obviously right before the
end of the year it is very cool for both
boys and girls
yeah and for nine - you know easily up
to 25 and then after that you have to be
really cool for you know but like like
literally but it's exactly you and I
literally even when you went back to
school I would argue just thinking about
my timing that it still hasn't really
penetrated guys yet it was like really
September October where I felt like oh
[ __ ] the guys Domino has now fallen this
is about to get [ __ ] crazy yeah I
mean people would ask me oh you have
followers like what's it on I'd be like
oh it's it's it's like social media I
don't know like you downplay I wouldn't
say Tech Talk cuz then people would be
like oh what are you seven yeah I feel
even I well she's your older sister
because she's supposed to do really
don't embarrass me yes that's so amazing
a conversation the big conversation
leading up to school starting she was
nervous cuz she was yeah thinking about
what kids would say when she got to
school or do tick-tock like even though
she had a lot of followers that was a
concern but then she started actually
getting like opportunities and making
money so then it was okay but the funny
thing is they all post on tik-tok - it's
just now that I have a following behind
me they're like oh that's cringy she
like actually tries like no all of you
guys try to of course there's all those
dynamics I think what's of course and
that will be no matter how big or small
platform is there's always like this
subconscious of like what kid teenagers
do to each other as they form their
self-esteem or lack thereof I think
what's more interesting for everybody
who's listening is the speed in which
the culture changes you know something
that you two won't know about but your
parents will there was something I used
to talk about I don't talk about a lot
now which was the stigma of online
dating in like the early 2000s like I
just remember because this is what I was
good
I'm like this is gonna be huge but for
years
I'm talking like 1996 I mean again three
of us know it was probably not until
like the late mm I would say was 2015
wasn't it tender come out maybe 14 15
like it took a good ten years fifty
twelve years of online dating being huge
before people would admit that they like
people lied for people got married
through match.com and made up stories of
how they met there was stigma the speed
in which tick-tocks positioning in
culture like saying it one more time the
fact that September 4th you're debating
whether you even want to let anybody in
school know that you're starting to get
viral I'm tick-tock - now every single
person in your school is either
subconsciously or consciously proud of
you the soci Asian and the whole thing
and also want it for themselves is just
an incredible change in temperature and
is very important for everybody's
listening because this is a business
podcast at the end of the day a lot of
entrepreneurs we talked in the past a
little bit about it like people say no
all the time I bet you subconsciously
Dixie's like [ __ ] maybe I should have
started three weeks earlier than they
actually did you know like it's what you
do it's what you do I mean me and the
team talked about it a lot too which is
like I think I sent something two weeks
ago I'm like we have to go harder
tick tock is crossing over even like we
need more content things that nature so
okay so you get to school and some
people know how's the first week like I
have what happens cuz at that point
going into September I still would what
do you were you a freshman or sophomore
deaf boy sophomore I would still argue
to your to agree with you it's still not
winning high school so that's September
you're probably still a little more like
in the shadows definitely I would say I
was very very shy about telling people
about it and I wouldn't say anything
unless they talked about it to me first
because I'm not going around school
saying like oh I I don't just talk of
course but it's just something that I do
for fun and of course some people had
their things to say about it and
I was like okay and then yeah just kind
of rubbed it off you know yep but no
matter what like I'm still having I was
still having fun doing it like dad where
are you in this whole mix when does it
hit your radar that there's something
brewing and end and I mean honestly -
you know where do you come from that you
know having you know teenage daughters
like I'm sure a lot of dads are
listening right now and like can
associate like you've got a different
perspective on this then mom does than
they do like where's your are you just
like looking to fight every dude on
tick-tock like where do you come at you
know it's funny we I noticed early on
and I've listened to you a lot and I've
noticed that you know we were just
really supportive from the beginning but
we started to see things when we were
out to dinner kids coming up and looking
at her and I was like why are they
people staring at us and then I started
to put it all together did that happen
during the summer yes that happened
during the summer we're up and we're up
in New Haven and when's the first time
somebody came up to you and said oh my
god you're Charlie from tick tock it
took a while people I would have I would
see people and I'd like why are they
staring at me what am i doing am i doing
something wrong and then I'd get but but
deanne later yeah don't play with me
here because I know you enough a little
bit like no that's okay you're humble
because you are a very humble girl but
like real life you knew what was
happening well maybe like you knew that
you were getting two million I got like
hundreds of thousands of views on it
take that bet theoretically a
thirteen-year-old might actually know
who you are it wasn't on my mind all the
time because I listen to guys like even
now it does not feel that way at all
when people are like like have that
feeling and like when I really at the
meet and greet in like hugging people
and they were shaking I was like like it
was like hitting me like this is real it
still is kind of like well there's a
difference between knowing and it being
surreal like like I was in the airport
yesterday and somebody comes up and just
started crying and telling me a story of
like how it helped her get out of a
toxic release but abusive toxic
relationship that's so real like I sit
there and I'm like my god me and my band
of misfits what else
but we put out stuff and it really helps
people
that's surreal but I know it's happening
you know what I mean Dixie's like like
you knew at that point when you did the
mean green we'll get to the meeting
greet which was a moment itself like
that that that knew there was things
going on but it was so real for you to
watch somebody Drive three hours and
shake and cry and hug your sister but
the thing is when you see people looking
at you you never think like oh they know
me from tik-tok I like especially on the
other way now if somebody kind of barely
glances at me at the airport but what
they're really mad is I might have cut
them in line at Starbucks what I'm
thinking is like I've changed their life
and they think I'm the coolest they want
a selfie and I can't wait to give it to
them
yeah I've completely phased that chasm
I'm joking but I just I don't think
about it all the time because once again
I'm just I'm dancing I'm just doing what
I've been doing my entire life taking
videos of myself dancing honestly I
think it's so new communicate I respect
the living [ __ ] out of you
keeping it in perspective I I think
what's gonna be really fun for me to
watch you go through is you not even
having to hedge that through
conversation you realizing your actions
will lead to that I mean it because
you're getting so much judgment it's so
front of mine for you to talk in the
demeanor you're talking I love it I
think it's gracious I just think I'd
like to tell you good news you just
acting the part will always work itself
out the world is undefeated in its truth
if you're good
it will play out if you're bad it will
play out if you get high on your own
supply and think you're somebody it will
play out regardless of the words you say
in public your actions will play out I
mean that that's why I want you guys
here I really think like there have been
listened to paint a picture if you're
not in tick tock culture this is not
just like people that have gone viral on
YouTube or Instagram like Charlie what
is your bio say on the tick tock don't
worry I don't get that
and what that means is you have that are
saying Charlie gained a ton of out how
many of you at ma'am
ten point six million love it so
obviously there's enormous growth of
following and by the way how many did
you have on on July fourth like three
thousand right so like you know real
hyper growth but like for everybody
understand that doesn't this wasn't just
another person that got a lot of
followers I think of Charlie the way I
think of DJ Khaled and Ashton Kutcher
and let me give a social media lesson
history lesson now it was Ashton Kutcher
going on CNN and challenging CNN to see
who would be the first account to get to
a million followers on Twitter that
really made Twitter hit like the public
consciousness and he was the human
associated with the thing it was dj
khaled getting stuck on in the water on
snapchat snapchat had already happened
but it was DJ Khaled and snapchat that
had their moment together
tik-tok had already happened but charlie
is that person for the tic-tock world it
just is that way it's true she was the
one that became like the thing and was
the one that has crossed over in a way
of recognition so it's it's a lot to
take on there's a lot of people which is
amazing about the world that have gotten
internet famous over the last decade
there's plenty of people there's a lot
there are far less people who are in the
moment you're in where like the whole
thing is about that thing for a little
bit and by the way and I think you're
probably already feeling this it's
already on the other side of it like it
all moves so quick like there was
absolutely two weeks where all of
tick-tock just decided everything was
about this girl and even though she's
still way up there in the biggest and
10.3 and all that stuff we're not in
exactly that moment yet because
attention spans and interests and memes
and culture move so quickly and I bet
you in a lot of ways that's good and and
in a lot of ways that is such a fun
moment to be in the eye of the storm and
by the way just like a hurricane the
storm is still very much
there right now but you might not be
necessarily in the deepest middle of the
eye um okay so when does the when does a
thawing out happen what does your older
sister succumb and say [ __ ] I need to be
able to train as well and I'm not gonna
make fun of you when do your friends
come on when des when do you start
feeling a tone and tenor and school
change when this when do things change a
little bit and and why was there a
singular video I want to hear for
everybody dicks
I see you want to jump in there what's
your what's your perspective it might
not be hers so we started having family
dinners and and Emily where you always
have been known that we we just started
okay ladies we sat down as a family
we're gonna start having the family
dinners cuz you all realize that Charlie
was gonna be moving away to Hollywood
let's have a couple of those Morgan
thinks he was going to college next year
nice going dick and I I was an on take
talk I was all my videos were private I
didn't have my name as my username no
one could find me yeah and all the
conversation at dinner
tick-tock tick-tock this person follow
me this this video you're so quick I
apologize no yeah give me cuz I want to
get this this like fun for me and I
think educational brothers who were some
of the people that followed you I'm
tick-tock that led to you cuz that's
what you're going through at first
you're not only getting the followers
like me and my team to this day when
like when the rock DM me or like like
Shawn Mendel a queer still freaking and
I love we are things like when it's like
a Jets the Jets kicker thicken the New
York Jets kicker followed me this week
on Instagram I was like losing my mind
on a plane last night thick like diems
okay you know like who who were some of
those early people for you it was all of
the people that were big on take talk
before I even got on to talk and I was
like why give me some shots so many it
was like anybody speak ok people that
are on like all the tours like all the
big tour more even got the app like
chase Taylor Brice all of them and like
and besides that just dancers
oh yeah McKenzie Ziegler following me I
was like losing your [ __ ] oh where were
you the second you saw that where was I
it was right after I did my first ever
interview with famous birthdays and I
just hit 500,000 and I had said in my
interview I really want to dance with
Maddie Mackenzie Ziegler one day and
then she followed me and I was like what
is going on what am i do why as my as
vice is happening she knows who I you
have enough of a platform were like this
is by the way like three years ago AJ
said to me hey can do me a favor can you
just shout out things that I want like
if I have want a pair of sneakers can be
like oh those new ones are cool because
I know something that's really cracking
the system fair enough and I've been
able to like build the relationship with
her where she was like hey I just made a
song like do you wanna take talk to me
and I was like of course like yeah of
course and she posted it on her
Instagram story and I was like this is
that and I was able i was able to meet
her at an event and it's just like what
is my like get it so dicks back to you
so tick-tock tick-tock tick-tock this
person's following me this person's
follow me you're like [ __ ] this is
supposed to be my year he's my last and
you're [ __ ] charlie stealing my [ __ ]
I need to [ __ ] figure this out yeah
okay so I was like all right you know
what she's about to hit 1 million
followers I was like Charlie let's make
a tick-tock I'm gonna change my username
let's do one together so we did one we
dressed the exact same and did a cool
thing like she cut me out and then we
switched spots or whatever and she
tagged me and I changed my username and
then it just started I was like I was
like okay I'm not gonna be annoyed by
this anymore I'm just gonna Klout chase
her a little bit but it was for my my
when I hit 1 million I was like okay
yeah we can do a video that was like the
rule she se was in some of her yeah
sprinkled throughout and people boy
she's a sister Wes who's that can I get
her ass yeah all right that's all we
were trying to add me on snapchat yeah
and then they did the big one and she
really started her account when the dad
become a phenom oh they love him yeah
I'm very aware of a attention everything
his fans they they only like him like
he's their Lord and Savior group ever
like to get the girls you know I was a
13 year old 15 year old 6 year old boy
at one time and this is kind of like
keep your friends close keep your
enemies closer
so it was just that's that's the
position I took [ __ ] how much of that is
a concern they're in like a very
interesting age to get this level of
exposure like how much does that run
through your mind I mean it's a concern
anyways and always I mean we I think we
talked to you about this but one of the
things we said and we maybe get to a
point of no return but I talk with him
every day if you guys are not happier
today than you were three months ago
then maybe we gotta pull the plug on
this thing you know it's funny you're
really not from a point of no return
she can have 47 million first so there's
a couple cool things that just like any
child star like clearly people have gone
in different directions right like Leo
DiCaprio ones this way like Punky
Brewster goes like you can all do
different [ __ ] what's really cool about
social is she's gonna have they're both
gonna have to like you're gonna have
like two moments one the one where you
decide where she goes you know if you
think about it at the age she's at right
now one could argue a common thing could
be she's on the verge of going to school
because she decides to and that's what
she wants and now she's now three full
years of this insanity and she might say
you know what for my freshman year of
college you know after what my big
sister told me I'm just gonna calm it
down this is where I'm gonna take I'm
just not gonna post for two months and
of course everyone's gonna still know
her and all that stuff but it is a
hamster wheel if you don't produce the
market will move there's you know we've
even seen this me educating the audience
you know the hype would Charlie has led
to other girls having to have hype and
then them
and just a fun thing for the boys to do
of like which girl do you think is cute
or funny or nice or whatever nonetheless
that will be the first moment where she
decides the second moment which has been
one of the most interesting things for
me to watch over the last 15 years in
analyzing social is the moment the
platform changes and she decides that
she want to take her equity to the next
thing or not
Tila Tequila and Dean cook one myspace
they did not take that equity and then
go in Twitter right DJ Khaled did not
take the equity from snapchat and went
ham on tik tok and could have and still
probably killed so there's these moments
of transition where the platform loses
its clout forget about the individual
and then the individual decides do they
want to siphon one of things that I
observed from watching from afar cuz I'm
watching everything is when Charlie
decided to start her YouTube platform
and how she's gone on her Instagram
platform that's a hedge which i think is
super smart gives her options but those
are gonna be the two moments by the way
your YouTube first video like how do you
announce it is still one of my favorite
moments of the year as someone who
cannot dance it was funny when you said
they're easy like anybody can do those
dances I was laughing I'm gonna not me
more simple a she talked about like
there are certain things I can really do
and then there's things I can't think
rhythm and these dances is not one of
the things but I you know I think I
think that that's gonna be the moments
she can always ban you really can
they'll always be the residual and at
some level already at this level of
notoriety in her age group it will carry
with her for hope for the very long time
it just changes you know there was a
point in time where people stopped
freaking out about you know Zack Morris
from Saved by the Bell and then it
becomes nostalgic and cool like like
that what's cool about this moment is if
she goes in a completely different
direction and what-have-you she'll be 36
and have somebody come up to her and say
hey you know who's up her age now so
it's there's a lot there we find that
and we've talked talked about this stars
at you and I probably know that kind of
drifted off and and so there's no part
of our life where we have a person come
up to us and
and it bothers us or we it's amazing
form and we've absolutely real
connection with you guys I've had I'm
the same and I've noticed that when
you're driven by gratitude of the
situation not getting high on your own
supply you know not thinking you're
better anybody not being overly worried
I think you guys have a really good even
keel to the whole approach I mean please
without this I would I'd be going to
school today like doing normal stuff and
I've been doing my whole life like I'm
just so thankful that I get
opportunities to do things like this
that if someone sees me and wants to
take a picture like I want to make sure
I give them my full attention so they
know that as much as they support me I'm
so thankful that they would ever even
think twice about me Charlie that's
amazing
at this point honestly it is at this
point what are you thinking about from a
creative standpoint forget about the
stuff we've been talking about you
inherently are a creative person you've
said you've danced your whole life
things that make sure so are you
starting to think about right now as a
creator for tick tock and then we'll
blend it into YouTube and Instagram and
other things if we want are you trying
to challenge yourself to come up with
new [ __ ] like what do you like what are
you thinking about right now as like
your next video so I've actually made
two of these point of view videos that
are so unlike me but I think it's so
cool that I can now use those two weeks
of just straight hey I got to use that
because now it just doesn't affect me I
just don't care let's talk about that so
they hate because of the Meetup because
of everything like just were just like I
don't go type I don't get it she's right
average and I was just like oh really
now I'm just like okay you're sitting on
at home on your phone writing hate
comments about a 15 year old girl like
right who's who's genuinely happier
right now
you changed us that day yeah we funny
yeah yeah that helped because it's hard
when we as parents it there we want to
wring people's necks and then we are we
have to be the adults and then they and
then you as in your level and and you've
dealt with this like we haven't dealt
with this so we didn't know about it and
it's easy and we've started to do
you know when people who are like say
not the really nasty stuff but some of
the negative we flip it around and joke
around like someone said to me the other
day today we're driving in I did
tick-tock and said you have to pay her
hundred seven dollars I said she gave me
a seven dollar discount it was a hundred
even yeah he's like and so we own it and
that's it it's empathy like I said that
day like I'm glad I know it's funny that
point of view I have I think it's helped
a lot of people and I actually think
it's the truth
like if you're in such a bad place that
you want to bring somebody else down I
actually I do feel empathetic I pleased
that that day after that day you hit her
first and she really took what you said
and ran with it it took us a little bit
longer yep it's just hard to see people
like coming out your kids Oh so we're Oi
yes and even she say like I'm not
getting upset about it you guys just
shouldn't care and we're like it's
really a perspective shift yeah and we
did after that day we were done I was I
was I was getting so upset and I was
like wow I guess I really am average
like it was just all running through my
head and I would just believe you were
so average that 29 percent of the
teenage boy population has devoted their
love to you that average I think one of
the things that she's had is like people
just saw her dancing and they didn't get
to really and what she's done and what
we've done as a family that people are
starting to know us as a family and
we're letting them into our lives and
they're saying wow they are there they
seem like such nice people they're
normal they deal with the same things we
deal with and that's changed a lot of it
that's also super important thing
Charlie listen this is now almost
talking about you as if you're not here
for me the thing that really mattered
about you for me was that you were a
girl that wasn't overly sexify your self
for the attention I thought it was a
super important I mean in the most macro
I mean this it was super important that
a girl like you came along and won
because it can show so many young girls
that you don't have to expose your skin
and and and I mean it's it's I actually
think it makes so much sense I think
America is very good and culture and
humans are very good at counter moves
I think we've just gone through an era
of very excessive sex efficacious of
young women with like surgeries and
clothes and things of that nature so I
think it just makes a lot of sense that
you became the countermove I really
believe that's what happened and I think
you you will be very proud as you get
older and and and think about you'll be
proud of your parents and proud of your
sister and proud of yourself
I think it's way bigger than you
actually it's way better than all four
of you realize I know it's way bigger
than almost every but this is the one
thing I'm good at
perspective right what I did for you
guys that day is perspective let me go
super high up there are millions of
girls right now in their brains that are
in a much better place because you came
along that's not necessarily and by the
way in a way to stay humble about it
that's not you that's just circum
there's a million things that went into
that but it's one of the great things
that happen in 2019 that it happened
because it's helped a lot of young girls
cuz when they look at you then I
could've minute I don't have to do this
that or the other thing to get the
attention of boys or people or followers
or clout that's a big breakthrough it's
a really nice moment and you and I I'm
really happy for the four of you that
you'll be associated with it because I
promise you in three four years people
catch up with my take on this and it
will be looked back at that moment
because I believed it to be true yeah
well you make my wife cry and honestly
it's the same way I think about
everything that happens for me and
anybody else if there's so many
variables that go into it there's so
many you know it's like you know you
don't have to overthink it but it is
wildly true I already I I watch I
already see it I already see it because
when that becomes the North Star
people parrot that behavior it's the
same way I feel about me as like an
influencer on Instagram as an alpha guy
using words like empathy and caring and
kindness it's changed things
you know I now see people I see guys
like guys guys like you know who like
try to be cool using nice words like
like it's an impact it's really cool and
I'm really happy that you'll be able to
like know how true that is over time
what about the Meetup
give us the 30 I just want to educate
the crowd so your start explode and how
does the concept come up like let's do
something for people to come and meet me
so what I was saying was no one's gonna
come this is gonna be horrible
I don't Becca yeah back up a little bit
oh so do D so my home dance studio has
no treble
yeah the spot just oh so my home dancer
you know that I've been going to you for
a long time it was like hey a lot of the
students know who you are and they
really like your tik-tok so you should
just come by and like say hi cuz you
know I I'm mostly trained in New York
City now so I'm not there as often as I
was a couple years ago and they were
like we'll just do like a quick little
like meetup thing like the people in the
CEO shoot of you should it's super
straight with me cuz this is what I want
from you because it will help people
there's the into it and the cringe part
of this moment right you've got a
hundred percent how much of you is in
the cringe part how much of you is like
you've seen all these other people you
know you're of the age where you know
what happened on vine and you know what
happened so you've seen meetups and
tours before it's not like you're like
what is this you're no dope we're where
do you sit on this as its approaching at
fifty fifty I was a hundred percent okay
I was like no Rick can I ask you a real
question then yeah if that's true did
you feel obligated to do the a nice
thing for the studio it wasn't that I
felt obligated it was that I talked
about it in one of my videos and I was
like would anyone comment everyone's
like yes I talked about it on a live
video it was like should I do it like I
don't know because at this point I was I
didn't feel like no one's gonna show up
to this I'm gonna post about it no one
hundred one hundred percent cringe never
leads to saying yes to it so that's why
I'm trying to figure out why you did it
well I was I were you curious how many
people show up okay that's where I
didn't know it was gonna happen
I'm very open did you feel deep down
again I'm trying to get you to say
things that you wouldn't normally say
cuz I think it would help people did you
you knew what the moment that you were
in was there a little back to curiosity
you knew there was some chance that it
was gonna be crazy not as crazy as it
was no it was it was just I had no idea
what I was getting myself into with this
yep I was just like Oh it'll be some
kids from what did you what did the
parent wouldn't you guys think about it
it was just she she didn't have I mean
she had a lot of followers but not like
crazy how many did you have at the time
okay and the far cry from 10 million
yeah and so it started out super simple
and so we're like we're not so I told
mark about it and he was like we're not
charging I'm like no nobody's in it to
make money just so he could like meet
some new kids and then I reached out to
the studio again I'm like alright we're
all in but it's just for the studio she
was like well I feel like maybe we could
like there's so many they are getting
phone calls is Charlie there what class
is she taking I want to take class here
so maybe we should put it for you know
put it out there yep and I was like okay
and then I said so just so you know
we're not we don't want to make money
off of it she was like no I see there
she's like well maybe we could do like a
fundraiser those family in the studio
whose daughter was diagnosed with ALS
that they wanted to help out I think
that's nice her friend by the way on the
record as an entrepreneur I actually
think sometimes having a charge for
something is a good filter to control
complete ridiculousness I really do
believe that like this notion and I
didn't follow this enough to know the
details that you're going into I know
enough to know that there was a donation
component that some people took out of
context this happens to everybody all
the time I'm just gonna go in a
different place with it which is this is
America if Charlie wants to charge eight
thousand dollars for someone to hop I
charge 200 thousand dollars to give a
speech that's more money that I made
that for the first five years of my
career working every day like
like don't count somebody else's money I
think we weren't pretending that there
we don't realize that there's potential
to make money in this we just didn't
want this first one to come across like
we're trying to go this is back to what
I said to Charlie earlier it was a
fundraiser absolutely the end 100%
people's hot takes or headline readings
never this is where we went wrong
and this is from being in experience so
her
so we're half was going to the family in
the studio the other half her friend has
a charity and who's gonna go to that
four cut kids with special needs
ok here was the problem done ok we'll do
an event bright there was a woman that
was helping us she was like have the
studio do an event right okay here's the
copy they put it up looked I looked at
it on like it looks good to me
debate it over the cost yeah oh let's
make the VIP a little bit nicer people
are coming by the way that's been
established forever
yeah that's how that's how Cameron
Dallas made money that's how you know
Nash Grier made money like that's how it
was done and a lot of them did it for
charity a lot of them did it for not
charity so when it was posted XP pulled
up Cameron dalas good so people read it
and they were like and then I think he's
super dreamy they just on the record and
oh and there's a seven dollar fee but
that's where it that's our thing it
turned on high I get it for everybody
who's not following along there was a
charity component people it sounds like
the execution could have been better
yeah so I don't have that lame people it
became a little bit of a storm like she
was 14 seconds into her fame she's
trying to make money it's the same old
[ __ ] it's actually a non-event because
the truth always kind of prevails I have
a far more important question Charlie
how many proms have you been invited to
like I need a real good guess from you I
could probably go to one every weekend
if I if I really
- and do you or than know but are you
gonna make some boys dream like are you
do blonde I did one yeah I went one last
weekend and he came to my meet and greet
and he asked me infinite oh I remember
that so I gotta go I went through with
it and it was good he was a very sweet
boy yeah they both were yeah it was fun
I mean it was old you go with dicks his
friends he was at the background of the
video dancing I was like that's so good
but it was like really fun it was really
fun yeah there was like only weird thing
people were like videotaping in the bath
wash my hands but yeah yeah it was fun
it was it was fun for the most part it
was something that I never would it was
like first ever formal with him Dan it
was like the winter formal yeah yeah I'm
like prom season first every school
dance with a boy a minute and
meet-and-greet was like exactly write it
up yeah you're a kid but I mean I was
just it is still fun I enjoyed myself
had a good time talking about the other
social networks real quick I'd love your
perspective so you blow up on this one
where do you sit on the others do you
like them do you think it's like smart
to do just in case you need it like
where are you where's your mind at what
the other platforms Instagram I use it a
lot I've had it for a long time yep so I
just enjoy posting pictures of me with
my friends I'm doing stuff photoshoot
pictures all that fun stuff snapped and
I use it my Instagram stories to like
keep people show and I'm doing Nina and
then snapchat I'll post on those stories
sometimes that's more where I post like
dancing improv stuff like that so you
want to see me dancing now as a place
for your actual friends it's the people
that I have added and they have added
they have me added back like those are
people that I talk to look when you talk
to your friends is it
texting is it Snap is it Instagram like
what is the equation app chat or texting
and calling yep so I'll use that to tell
you - and sometimes yeah I I watch you -
sometimes what about you posting on it
uh
I'm working on it I'm not it doesn't
come natural to you yeah it's just it's
a lot harder yeah take talk so I'm still
getting used to it but I would love to
be able to post on it a lot more show
people my personality what about Twitter
I just got verified on Twitter which is
like crazy but um my tweets are kind of
all over the place like I tweeted I
would like a Dunkin Donuts brand deal
because I drank one two three cups of
cold brew coffee a day so and then
Duncan replied it was like what is going
on I tweeted app Duncan known as just
replied to me my life is now complete
like I'll just be like just do the
renegade dance and move on you know it's
so it's just like random things like
that I don't use it for anything
important just to tweet whatever I'm
thinking any other platforms to look at
her use but that's just like for
pictures that I don't feel like posting
on Instagram because like Instagram is
more good pictures that are this more
like person yeah yes these are like
pictures I took like a selfie if you
know the same in theory the same way you
think about stories like yeah understood
dad what do you think about all this
where are you guys at at this exact
moment what's the State of the Union
we're having fun we're balancing it all
and and we're taking one day at a time
you know it's it's not so easy like
every day there's a new opportunity a
new thing and it's just like it's it's
kind of like fun that wedding part of it
yeah yeah but that's the way our life
was before this right I work I'm in the
clothing business I work from home I
have an office in the city so I'm not a
nine-to-five or never have been on my
own clothing brand so we would I mean we
we sat home on a Christmas night one
night and we're just like guys let's get
out of here and we got on the plane and
went to Miami for like we're that time
there was a spontaneous element to the
family to begin with and yeah and the
cool thing about like I think where this
she there were definitely pivotal
moments in her in this whole thing and
one of them was she knew enough to say I
was going on to California for a
business trip and she's like dad can I
can I come and I know and I'm not trying
to Pat myself on the back but I know
other parents or some parents like no
way might have said what are you kidding
me
got this and I was like cool let's go
get your hit and she came she stayed in
the hotel with me she went out and met a
bunch of these other tik-tok errs I
brought it a famous birthdays and that's
just kind of the way we roll so we're
taking one day at a time and what's on
your mind these days it's just so much I
I I'm wondering if there's gonna be a
time where it's a little easier to mmm
just have a complete thought oh oh and
this let's talk about this know out of
everybody sitting at this table you
understand this the best do you remember
when you had Dixie yes of course do you
remember how [ __ ] insane those first
couple weeks worth do you remember how
eventually there was a time where you
could like settle in okay yeah think
you're welcome
really really like you know as I really
think you can relate to that yeah I
think that's what's gonna happen I
needed that you're welcome this is what
I do every something yes what about for
you um it's very crazy I've never been
more happy that I got into college in
August before school even started
because if I was doing that right now I
don't think I would have made the
tic-tock account or continued
interesting so you wage things yeah the
way things worked I if I wasn't in
college right now like already like my
school would not be I was okay with me
missing this me classes and my parents
are still saying like schools the number
one priority I'm like how every this
weekend we had we we had I had an off
day and went to Jingle Ball and then we
went to the meet-and-greet and then we
went through school dance and then we
went to a meet and greet and then I went
to school the next day like I don't know
what are your friends sang to you when
you show up randomly once every two
weeks like there's nothing better than
friends
right like you walk right in and they
like complete just start [ __ ] on you
yeah I know just what are you saying ask
me questions yes I know I have a jam on
my tooth
like it feels good like seeing them and
I miss like hanging out with all my
friends but I just you just know it's a
moment mm-hmm you're gonna squeeze it
yeah and we're not pushing them for work
I think which he means to say what I've
said is we want you to have options if
she goes if she's a go-go in Alabama and
also in Jesus is well yo being
entrepreneurial really helps people
don't understand the value of
optionality I I mean the single reason
that I've built a brand a personal brand
is four options there's nothing better
than options and and I think what
attracted to me to you you guys was the
amount of times I've walked into the
moment that I walked into a month ago
with you with you guys and I said it to
you too immediately and saw oh this
could get ugly fast and to see that not
be I there are very few lien again
either sports representation business so
we're seeing families all the time that
have kids are about to go to the NFL I'm
living the life that I'm living I see a
lot of [ __ ] like I said it to you
Charlie then I'll say it again like
you're very very very fortunate cuz it's
very hard for parents to calibrate this
moment very hard and it's really cool
thank you it's really really really cool
it really really really matters and I
think for a lot of people that are
listening right now DMing you know the
parents for like thoughts on this I
think it really matter I would actually
try to compel the two of you to consider
starting a podcast or putting out
content from a complete perspective of
parent that I think could really help
you know I really do I really do mean
that because I don't think people
understand how calm when I wrote crush
it my first book like if you read that
right now and I wrote in 2008 I
basically wrote about Charlie
like I basically wrote like hey don't
get this twisted this is what the
Internet's gonna do it's gonna turn a
ton of normal people into different
versions of celebrity not everyone most
people will never get to Charlie's level
most people not amassed 10 million
followers on a platform let alone a
single platform overall but everybody is
in a place of fifteen hundred three
thousand and guess what and you probably
remember this 3,000 feels like 10
million
let me remind everybody that she worried
about her next post after the first one
so we're all living on the record in a
way that we've never had and there's a
lot of reframing conversations that
society needs to deal with it and I
believe it can be very good and yet
everyone I mean the amount of judgment
you two are getting from your parenting
peers without them knowing anything
right yeah is enormous and it's it takes
a lot of self-esteem as parents to be
able to continue to doing what's right
for the girls a lot harder than people
realize a lot harder and I think they're
they're very good about keeping us in
check we still do chores well no like
people think that's great you don't have
a robot doing that for you yet and I was
like I put in a vlog it was like yeah
okay it's time to go into the dishwasher
and people like oh my god someone
somebody reached out and they it was
about a job that she was they wanted her
to do whatever and they said you know I
messaged her and she hasn't gotten back
I'm like cuz I ever fall until her rooms
clean so sorry if they're just like you
still do that like yeah yeah that's why
the friends are good too yeah I think
that's why I want to ask you that like
I'm like pumped that's what friends are
for your friends are there for when you
come back to like ground you yeah and
then you've got each other yeah that's
been that's been huge are you kidding
like I think that siblings are such a
special thing and I always think
siblings shine in two extreme moments
this great moment but it's a lot or like
real tragic moments and so like they
have a lot of similarities where you get
into a little bit of a cocoon and I
think it's gonna be foundational for
them and honestly watching the whole
thing go down I actually have a ton of
empathy for the humility that Dixie had
to execute back don't we touched on it a
little bit here but I want to say this
cuz I think there's a lot of siblings
out there right now that their younger
sibling has something happening and
they're doing everything they can to not
lean into it because they don't have the
humility to do it and I think it's
coming at the detriment of both people
in that scenario
so it was really fun for me to watch
again from afar I'm like good for her
because think guys
Dixie doesn't want her friends making
fun of her that she's like you know
flexing off of her little sister like
that's exactly what her friends like
that people don't remember like how it
is like that's exactly what I would do
if she was my friend inscrutable you
know like you know like that takes a
level of humility and I think I don't
know I think there's been a lot of great
acting here with this family and I
appreciate it and I'm really excited
that a whole new audience is about to
know who you guys are and that's why I
wanted you on and I wish you the best
New Year's
you